you might be saying well uh jair
bolsonaro must be right in there right
he must be right in there with the
insurrectionists and the terrorists and
the Riders saying I support you and
we're going to get this thing back but
that is absolutely not the case
bolsonaro and we're quoting the New York
Times here has been holed up thousands
of miles away
in the U.S state of Florida
before departing Brazil the former
president urged his supporters to avoid
violence Jack nikis wrote this article
for the times it was updated just a few
hours ago when his supporters stormed
Brazil's Congress and presidential
offices on Sunday to protest what they
falsely claimed was a stolen election
Jairo bolsonaro was believed to be
thousands of miles away facing various
investigations from his time in office
bolsonaro fruit of Florida in late
December with plans to stay for at least
a month he's been in Orlando living in a
rented house owned by a professional
mixed martial arts fighter a few miles
from Disney World
bolsonaro has long questioned the
reliability of Brazil's election systems
without evidence and he refused to
concede unequivocally when he lost in
October to president Lula who took
office on January 1 yet before departing
for Florida in the final days of his
presidency bolsonaro called on his
supporters to avoid violence and
suggested that they move on we live in a
democracy or we don't he said no one
wants an adventure Sunday evening he
criticized the protest saying on Twitter
peaceful demonstrations are part of
democracy but destructions and invasions
of public buildings like what occurred
today were not he also repudiated
president Lulu's comments that bolsonaro
bore some responsibility for the riots
saying that those accusations were
without proof there is some really
really wild video of bolsonaro in
Florida it just it's kafka-esque I know
it's for for the first time in 2023 I'm
pulling the term out it is sort of
kafka-esque here is video of bolsonaro
in a Publix just kind of like looking
around it's it's surreal almost and he
seems to have security with him
there he is
checking out the register
and it kind of looks like security is
checking out for him which is
interesting I mean that seems like an
interesting grocery store experience
you're just like I'd like this yes sir
yes sir right in the cart and then they
they handle it so so bolsonaro can just
look around
pacing aimlessly and in Publix
waves to the person filming uh yeah you
know
uh wow did did you know these granola
bars have four grams of fiber per
serving this is stuff we don't have
these in Brazil just bizarre and of
course the bigger questions here are
about his legal status in the country
I'm not going to pretend to know the
details of bolsonaro's legal status in
the country there's a few different
things that are possibilities and and I
don't know that we necessarily know
commenters in Brazil are saying
bolsonaro is in the U.S on a diplomatic
Visa now of course the Diplomatic Visa
is no longer valid in the sense that he
entered on the Diplomatic Visa in
December when he was still president
he's not currently president
now the question starts to be is he
overstaying the Visa in a sense because
he was on the Diplomatic Visa he's no
longer a diplomat does that make him an
overstayer
it's doubtful that that's classified as
an overstaying Visa visas are usually
valid for a certain period of time and
once that time elapses it starts to
become an overstay if the person hasn't
left or renewed the Visa or obtained a
new Visa or immigrated in some different
way we don't actually know how long
bolsonaro is really planning to stay now
there are people talking about criminal
charges and what happens if bolsonaro is
criminally charged for something and
it's conceivable that that would happen
in that case I would suggest a package
deal extradite him with George Santos
right back to Brazil and let's make sure
that the legal legal system does does
what it's supposed to do but regardless
there's a lot of speculation as to the
legal status and the immigration status
I assure you
the state department is very much aware
of Gyro bolsonaro being in Florida
how he got here and how long he can stay
and I am sure it will all ultimately
shake out but the imagery and I don't
even know whether at KFC he was doing
crispy strips of the or the bucket of
chicken or what that is reporting I
would certainly like to learn more about
and whether he thought that the coleslaw
uh had Mayo which apparently it doesn't
apparently the coleslaw KFC is
completely vegan much to the surprise of
many no answers to those questions but
you're sort of hanging around while his
supporters are rioting in support of him
in uh in in Brazil so bizarre and wild
stuff and we are going to talk after the
break about the fingerprints that are
all over this Insurrection and you might
not be surprised to hear
that many of those fingerprints are the
Fingerprints of people who worked in and
around the Donald Trump White House so
that'll be after the break Wednesday
January 11th two days from now is the
first David packman show Town Hall of
2023. everyone is invited everyone can
participate and talk to me we will be
handling the uh uh the the platform we
will use for you to talk to me is
Discord you can find our Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord if you are a
website member you will get Priority
Access meaning we'll I'll take more
calls from website members than
non-members but everyone is welcome and
we're going to take calls from everybody
it will be and I I really want to be
clear because people said what's the
date what's the time I'm telling you
right now okay write this down Wednesday
January 11th at 6 PM Eastern Time 3 P.M
Pacific time
the event will stream
and to call you go to davidpackman.com
Discord we will take a quick break and
continue with so much of the news from
the weekend
there is something you use at home every
day that is significantly harming the
planet and it is your toilet paper 30
million trees are destroyed every year
for toilet paper in the U.S alone
deforestation is a contributor to
climate change and I think moving away
from tree based toilet paper is
something we can all do and that's why I
asked real paper to be our sponsor real
paper is a toilet paper made 100 from
bamboo stocks which grow forever so no
cutting down trees and all of real
papers packaging is plastic free think
of all those big plastic bags you've
thrown out over the years real paper is
a b Corp certified by the forest
Stewardship Council and real paper
plants one tree with every purchase you
make and the best part is you can do a
part to fight climate change without
making any sacrifice because real paper
is soft and fluffy and durable just like
traditional toilet paper you're used to
guys this is a no-brainer for anyone who
cares about the issue of deforestation
give real paper a try go to
realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for 30 off your first order plus
free shipping the link is down below